the question of how far we can go when
we enhance or adjust or touch up an
image in science is a critical one you
are all familiar I'm sure with the
stunningly beautiful Hubble images
published all over the world but most of
the world is not familiar with the fact
that the colors as seeing were
artificially created decided and
implemented by humans you can read a
conversation I had with some of these
researchers in American scientists in
the resource section look for this
thumbnail I think you'll find the
article interesting about the decisions
the researchers made about coloring the
detail of nebula so in essence the
coloring or enhancement was mostly done
for the purpose of communicating
structure and I would say also for
helping bring attention to these amazing
images now remember these pictures of
the universe are representations that is
reason tations they are photographs of
that universe they are not the universe
all the photographs in this course and
the ones you are making and will make
represent various structures and
phenomena in order to communicate
research you the image maker has to make
decisions in order to make these re
presentations as I do
should I make an image of this or that
shall I compose it this way or that when
shall I set up my camera in the winter
or in the summer at five minutes of the
phenomena or three days later what tool
shall I use should I use a scanner or a
stereo microscope what lighting setup
should I use what background is best so
in a way the whole process
a photography requires us to make
decisions about making adjustments for
the purpose of communication the
question we must ask ourselves is do any
of these choices Mis represent reality
so that process of selecting colors in
the Eagle Nebula is similar to my
process when I colored this image which
was originally grayscale I made the
image with electrons on a scanning
electron microscope an SEM we needed
electrons to see the nano wires they
were too small to use photons as we do
in photography
once again the purpose here is to show
more clearly the structure the
difference between my adjustment and the
astronomers adjustment is that the color
choices of the researchers in the
article were informed by chemical
characteristics of the various areas of
the image my choices in this particular
case was purely aesthetic but first and
foremost with any work in science
whenever we color any SEM or other image
we must always indicate what we have
done period somewhere near the image not
on another page we have to dig deeply to
find to see what's going on here
somewhere near the image we must say
this image was color enhanced the
subject of enhancement is not discussed
enough in your training many of you just
assumed that certain adjustments can be
made in software on your pictures that
is not the case I can't possibly go
through every example of adjustments at
this point but I'd like to encourage you
to start thinking about it from the very
beginning when capturing your work when
you start a particular investigation
which you will be submitting for a
publication when you start documenting
the work as evidence of your research
just as important I'm encouraging you to
have this kind of conversation we
your colleagues to create a mindset in
your lab of do's and dont's we just
don't talk about it enough
so let's even start with these videos
you've been watching for our course I
mentioned to you in the Welcome video
that I digitally clean some of the
images that you're looking at the reason
I gave you for getting rid of the Spetz
was so that you would not be distracted
by imperfections in the various samples
that I photographed well that was a
decision I made for this particular
purpose for this course to teach you
about process and most important is the
fact that I informed you of my
adjustment however if you are submitting
an image for a published figure to a
journal well that's a whole different
story I was privileged to have a long
conversation with a few editors and the
art director at nature we discussed a
number of examples you'll be seeing here
we talked about what is permitted and
what is not
first we concluded that the rules for
cover images are different from images
in figures nature regards cover
submissions more as illustration or art
and in that case one is permitted to
clean some specks and distracting
material and to add color for example if
the image is initially in black and
white here's a picture I made starting
with the unadjusted image of the yeast
colony and here I digitally deleted the
petri dish because I wanted the viewer
to see the stunning morphology of the
colony the data in the image is the
morphology of the colony I'm not
adjusting that data
I am simply removing the part of the
image that in my opinion is unnecessary
or distracting although not everybody
agrees with me science did permit that
adjustment for the cover and once again
I described the adjustment in the cover
caption here I made this image of a
device on film so because the lighting
of the lab created a green
cast its how the film read the scene my
adjustment of the color was trying to
get the image to what my eyes saw and in
my opinion is acceptable and this one
taken under a stereomicroscope
we see an artifact of the process a
reflection of the lens on the wafer and
so here I removed the reflection again
always indicating what I've done in this
one which you've seen before I first
used a stereo microscope but because
with this tool I didn't have control
over the direction of the light we're
seeing all sorts of distractions in the
second image which I made with a camera
and a lens the image is cleaner I did
not digitally clean the specs it just
looked better with this equipment and
this lighting or let's take this device
one step further where I made this
detail with a microscope using a
technique in microscopy called in a
Marquis differential contrast which
emphasizes surface structure based on
the index of refraction that's why
you're seeing all these colors so all
these decisions address which tool shall
I use basically adjusting my point of
view which translates into adjusting the
final image this one is a more
complicated question which the editors
and I discussed at length in effect we
started having a conversation about what
is reality which is a subject I promise
we're not going to pursue here but in
essence this is a question that should
be somewhere in the back of your
thinking after all you are making
representations of reality aren't you so
here's the image which I hope gets you
to think a little bit these are rods
measuring about 2 to 3 centimeters long
all of which have absorbed fluorescing
material this is the image I captured on
film under UV light however my eye saw
this image with orange rods it turns out
the
film did not capture the orange
wavelength so I digitally adjusted those
rods that were supposed to appear Orange
that adjustment was not acceptable to
the editors it turns out in my opinion
the adjusted image was closer to reality
than the unadjusted image what do you
think and take this one here's the
original image of these amazing Proteus
colonies growing in a petri dish as it
happens the agar is cracking in a few
places I made the image for the book on
the surface of things the point was to
show how the colonies grow and I didn't
want to detract the reader from the
point of the image so I digitally
deleted the cracks now the nature
editors all agreed this would never be
accepted for a figure in their journal
which makes sense but what about a book
for the public what do you think here's
an image from another of my articles in
American scientists look for the
thumbnail again under the resources I
very mistakingly deleted a small speck
in the middle of the glowing circle here
I did so after asking the researcher if
I could do so and he very politely said
it was fine but years later when we
discussed the article I realized that
that deletion was very improper it turns
out that that small speck had an
important effect on the final outcome of
the image I guess at the time he was
trying to be easy and the article was
not part of a journalist submission but
now and we both agree the mistake was
clearly mine I had no right to adjust
that image even after asking for
permission
here's that adjustment by the way you
saw before reverting a grayscale image
and the editors did accept that at
nature now how about this one
it's true that these are microscopic
images and beyond the realm of the
course but I thought it would be
important for you to think about it
the researchers supplied me with two of
their original images
the colored areas gave highly detailed
morphological information about the cell
as specific quantum dots attached to
specific structures when the dots are
excited with UV light they fluoresce and
so we see where they attach in standard
views of fluorescently labeled material
the colored areas are set against a
black background I thought it would be
interesting and maybe more communicative
to see the information differently as
long as I maintain the integrity of the
science so I inverted the two images in
Photoshop to give a white background but
because it was important to keep the
original colors of the structures
themselves I change the colors back to
the red and green I then layered both of
the images over a third image taken with
standard microscopy again supplied by
the laboratory the three layered results
shows the same information as the
original separate images with the
addition of a sense of the whole I'm
showing you where the structures are I'm
not quantifying the amount of quantum
dots present another form of adjustment
changing histograms can also be part of
our conversation here's an old gel run
created a while ago when the runs were
still captured on film the point I want
to make here is still relevant so here I
am zooming into a portion after I
changed the histogram for the whole run
now that's important I didn't take a
portion in this one I adjusted the
contrast even more and on this one even
more to better see the band's now what
do you think about this is this
permitted the editors at nature were
initially comfortable with the
enhancements since the adjustment was
universally made to the entire image and
later in the conversation they
emphasized the requirement
to indicate how that image was enhanced
okay so what about this one the tank
you're looking at was used to study
sediment rates of sand and it was too
large to photograph in one image and so
I made the couple of images and
superimpose them for a journal article
you'll notice I stitched the two images
together showing the fact that there are
two images you're seeing the overlays I
did the same for this image this time
microscopic again since it wasn't
possible to show the whole device in one
image and here again I decided to
include the boundaries to each image
letting the viewer know the full image
is a collage and for this one the
researcher made single SEMS and used
Microsoft software to stitch the pieces
together for the article here we cleaned
it a bit what do you think once again I
want to say there are so many
possibilities in this conversation but
it's critical that you keep all of these
questions in mind when you talk to each
other and certainly when you start
thinking about communicating your work